okay Justin is leaving if you don't have
your quizzes in already he's not going
to take
them okay for those of you who are in my
corporate finance class you kind of know
what's going to
happen so Michael is going to tell the
class exactly what's going to happen
next Michael
on to you so what happens next well we
start class I start class so that's good
so that's the first priority we'll come
to that um second Justin is going to
take the quizzes upstairs and put them
in alphabetical order and you will leave
it on my desk I have a stack of
corporate finance exams see I'm first in
first out I'll grade those and then I'll
turn to your quizes your quizzes grade
them once they're graded you will get an
email and it'll be a very cryptic email
saying your quizzes are done come and
get
them and I will attach the solutions
with the grading template to the quiz
the reason I don't want to cover the
solutions now is you will freak out you
will assume the worst case scenario it's
best to not look at the solutions I'm a
very very very generous grader so there
will be partial credit for things you
didn't even think you deserve partial
credit for so that's why why if you left
a problem
untouched don't ever do that again cuz I
can't give partial credit for nothing on
the paper now show me you are trying at
least to get to a destination and I will
go along with you I'm
also a speedy but noisy grader what does
that mean I don't see the point of 100%
Perfection here so I would grade I will
make mistakes the grading template is
there in case I make a mistake don't
and mourn about it just bring it
no bring it to my attention I'll give
you the extra points okay so we'll put
it aside you will you will hear from me
sooner than you think okay and then you
can come pick up the quizzes they'll be
the reason I asked you to write the your
name on the back of the quiz is they'll
be face down in a stack and I'll tell
you where to come and get them just take
your exam out of the stack check it
against the solution and we're done so
today I want to talk about
growth you've all picked company and I
was looking at the master list there are
a few stragglers still who kind of hold
out but the problem is I don't know
whether You' dropped the class and
therefore you don't have to fill in the
name so the my list is a little outdated
so I will assume each of you has a
company that you P you have to estimate
growth for your company right so I'm
going to start off today by talking
about the different ways you can
estimate growth but before I do that I
want to set something on the table that
I've talked about all through this class
growth by
itself is neither good nor bad it's just
that there's a good side of growth
what's a good side of growth your
revenues get larger your earnings get
bigger you get to be a bigger company
the bad side of growth is you got to
reinvest to deliver the growth
intuitively you can already see how you
can grow and Destroy value right if you
reinvest huge amounts and get very low
or even moderate growth you're
destroying value so we're going to talk
about metrics we can use for destroying
value but the net effect of growth is
what we're searching for
so there are three generic ways only
three generic ways in which you can try
to estimate the growth for your company
the first is you can look at the past
what kinds of companies is that going to
be most helpful
on stable mature companies in businesses
that are not being disrupted right so
you got to be careful you can have a
stable mature company with the
businesses so we start with that it's
called historical growth unfortunately
in 75% of valuations this is it you see
why I said
unfortunately you don't need a person
right cha PT could do that for you so
we'll start with that and I'll talk
about all the pitfalls when talk about
historical growth the pitfalls you can
run into second you can Outsource growth
why do we do
that why in general do we ask somebody
else to tell us what to
do I always ask my spouse can you make a
list of what I have to get at the
grocery store you know why because if I
don't get something on the list then
it's not on the L you told me to get it
I just got what you we Outsource things
because we don't want to take
responsibility for it and when valuing
companies it's so easy to Outsource the
growth to people that we think are more
expert than we are because they know
they hang out with the company either
management because after all management
knows more about the company than you do
terrible mistake if you ask me or
analysts because after all they spend
all of their time estimating growth for
the company
the third way you can estimate growth is
to look into the company growth is not a
magical number that you and I can go
around IND Dow companies with it has to
come from choices or decisions a company
makes and they're painful you got to
reinvest a lot so you got to give up
current cash flows and second and this
is difficult you got to reinvest
well we're going to look at how looking
at what companies put back into the
business and the quality their
investment
is actually going to tell you how much
they're going to grow historical growth
outside estimates of fundamentals so
let's start with the easiest of those
three historical growth rate should be a
fact right so when I ask you what's the
growth rate in your company you expect a
number this shouldn't be up to debate
but it turns out that even that number
can be skewed by choices you make so I'm
going to talk about how those choices
can be affected by the time periods you
look at how you comput your average
growth rate arithmetic averages versus
geometric
averages and how the metric used to
compute the growth rate can give you
very different numbers you know what I
mean by Metric when I ask you growth
rate in your company I didn't specifying
what right it can be in revenues it can
be in operating income in Abit EIT net
income I'm going to give you at least a
general pattern you should expect to see
in those growth rates when you look at a
typical form and finally there's a math
problem in Computing growth rate for
some kinds of companies how do we
compute growth rate can somebody give me
the Leon how do you compute the growth
rate in New Year what do you
do just give me the mathematical formula
I have a number from last year a number
from this
year take the change change and then I
divide by the number from last year
right what if the number from last year
is
negative it's going to create a math
mess for me because my my earnings might
go from negative to positive but
Computing a growth rate itself can
become problematic that's the first math
problem the second is when you look at
growth even if you don't have negative
earnings if your company is going from
small to large while you're watching it
the growth rate might in fact be a
number you can't
sustain so let's start with the first of
those and I'm going to go back way back
in
time to the peak of the do boom when
Motorola was the also ran in the race
that other young tech companies winning
motol has been around a long time so
1994 through 1999 I've computed the
growth rates in in three metrics
revenues Abit diabet in fact the actual
book I also did net income earnings per
share and I'm going to ask you to try to
guess what those numbers would look like
so I took the numbers for six years to
get five years of growth rate and you
always need six to get to five because
you need the change I've competed the
growth rate each year and I've computed
an average growth rate over the first
five years the first average is just an
arithmetic average I just add the five
numbers up and divide by five and the
arithmetic average growth rate and
revenues is about 7% it's about 11% in
Abit and about 42% in evit that's
impressive right before you get too
impressed with that arthic average I've
also computed a geometric
average you know how we compute
geometric averages we take the ending
number
3931 you take the starting number and
then you take it to the root 1/5 why
because you're looking at the it's a
it's a compounded average for revenues
the numbers are pretty similar right
7.08 versus 6.8% he saying why do you
even waste your time as you go from
revenues to EIT to ebit notice the
difference
widens there's a statistical reason it
they widen if you look at the standard
deviation below of the earnings think
about the only scenario where arithmetic
average growth rates and geometric
average growth rates are going to
converge Michael what has to be true
about the growth rates for the two to be
exactly the same
number or small standard zero standard
if you have 8% every year the arithmetic
average is 8% and I can guarantee you
the geometric average will also be 8% as
the standard deviation increases the two
numbers will deviate I haven't shown you
net income and earnings per
share those differen are going to be
even wider because as you go down the
income statement everything gets more
volatile because you got fixed costs and
interest
expenses if you're looking at growth
rates in earnings per share for your
company my wager is or in on in earnings
for your company my wager is in most
Services you're going to get growth
rates in earnings per share so when you
see a reported growth grow rate of 7%
for the last 5 years before you use it
you first have to say is that an
arithmetic average or a geometric
average it can make a huge difference
arithmetic averages in general mean very
little especially when it comes to
earnings because if you look at the ebit
it starts at 2.6 billion ends at 3.2
billion there is zero chance that you
actually got a 42% growth growth rate
every year arithmetic was geometric
averages let's stay on that and let's
deal with this question of negative
earnings so Time
Warner 5 Cent loss in 1996 has a 25 cent
gain in 97 in earnings per share first
if you think in terms of what happened
to earnings per share was this a good
year or a bad year you went from -5
cents you're moving in the right
direction right if I ask you to compute
a growth rate
though think of what you're going to get
as an answer dicka what's my growth rate
going to be if I follow the conventional
equation what's the change in earnings
over
there 30 cents what do I divide
by the earnings last year which was -5
cents what's 30 divid -05
600% - 600% you saying that makes no
sense I agree with you when your numbers
go from negative to positive the growth
rate should really be written as not
meaningful but the problem is when you
been doing this big Excel spreadsheet
and you're not checking you're letting
the growth rates be computed always add
an if before you do it if the earnings
in the previous year are negative put in
not available otherwise you're going to
get the strange looking number pulling
all your numbers
apart there are all these little fixes
that have been devised for negative
earnings one of the see one of the fixes
is what's causing the problem the
negative in the denominator right can I
take the negative and make it a positive
yes I can make the ma equation absolute
value of earnings I fix the problem
problem mathematically because now my -
600 becomes plus 600 the sign makes
sense but the number makes no sense so
when you look at all the different fixes
you can use a higher of the two numbers
you can change a negative number to a
positive number I can give you fixes to
get a growth rate but none of those
numbers will tell you much about the
future final point and this is a scaling
effect on Dr you heard of caway
go what did the make what what product
brought them to the
Limelight and what was the name of the
golf
club the very first one the one that
made them with they are is the big Bera
right I don't play golf but this must be
some one big Golf Club I guess but it
was a new product that came out and of
course golfers always blame their
equipment for not
shooting what they need to shoot so they
the perfect Market is I've got the
perfect that's why I've been shooting 98
if I get that i' shoot like Tiger Woods
it never works but the big birth it took
off and as it took off the net profit
for Callaway golf went from 1.8 million
to
122.3mi average growth rate so I'm not
even playing the arithmetic average game
the geometric average growth rate over
those years was 122% so I'm actually
reporting the truth about the past so
let's say in 1996 you're trying to Value
caway golf you're using earnings per
share you're drawing on past growth and
you put in the 122% growth rate for the
next 5
years here's what your Ned enome look
like five years from now if you flesh
out the story what will this
require that each and every one of us
even we don't play golf should have to
buy a big birther put it in the closet
maybe as a
weapon but this is what happens when you
take historical growth rates for small
companies and just plug it into the
future because it'll cause your numbers
to explod so if you're working with a
small company be very very cautious
about historical growth rates not that
they're a lie but as you scale up it get
more and more difficult for those growth
rates to
continue one final point about
historical growth about 50 years ago
this this guy does a PhD his name was
IMD little he was British he comes over
to do a PhD at one of the research was
in Harvard Yale something and he decides
to test a hypothesis the hypothesis he
was testing was does knowing past growth
help you predict future growth he took a
few hundred companies the sample size
would be small then because you hand
collected the data and he did a very
simple test he looked at the earnings
growth from 1951 through 56 for each
company which he
knew and then he also looked at the
earnings growth from 1957 to 1962 which
he was also so he had two 5year growth
periods and what was he trying to test
does knowing the growth in the first
period help you predict the growth rate
in the second period right so think of
running a statistical test you're
running a correlation between the two
numbers I'm before I ask you to guess
what if found as a correlation I'll give
you the title of his thesis it was
higgledy piggledy
growth some British Nursery rhy I guess
is coming into play but you need don't
even need to understand higgledy
piggledy and and you can pretty much
guess what he found his correlation
right what do you think has found his
correlation he found
zero if he got a really high positive
number or really high negative number
either would be useful right you got a
high positive number what would mean if
you have companies with high growth
they're likely to grow at a high rate if
you got a really high negative number
you reverse that process you get
zero I'm not saying past growth is
useless but you have to be really
careful about extrapolating it because
historically it's not been that good at
forecasting future growth so any
questions about historical growth for
some of you this question is off the
table why because your company's been
around only 2 years but if your
company's been around as long as
Coca-Cola Disney Try playing this game
look at different time periods starting
point ending point to see what happens
to your growth rate let's now talk about
analysts now start of the class I told
you how s equity research analyst can
either be sside analyst or buy side
analyst B analysts are seldom seen they
never heard because they work at
companies they go back home and nobody
but analysts are out there in fact
that's their job to get out there know
on on get their names
reported and let's let's State a few
things about cide equity research ANS
their job at least in theory is to find
buy and sell right list out which
companies Buy in their set and they
spend a
disproportionately large amount of their
time focused on earnings rather than on
valuation and a disproportionately
portion of that time focused on next
quarters
earnings now some of you might have know
noticed that Invidia came out with an
earnings report what Wednesday or
Thursday of last week after close of
trading Invidia is tracked by like 75
analysts now and I'm sure the entire
last few weeks has been spent trying to
forecast what that number will be you
think they're done you know what they
start on today what the next quarters
earnings are going to be their entire
lives are built around forecasting
getting the next earnings
so you saying so they so they spend a
lot of time on these companies they're
forecasting these earnings numbers the
question then is they must be coming up
with better estimates of growth rate
than most other
people those are the numbers you see
reported in Yahoo finance or Zach as the
growth in earnings for the
company so let's take a closer look at
analyst forecast of earnings first to
see if they're better than just even
using historical data they should be
able to beat that right if nothing else
because of have information that's not
in the time series all the reports that
come out about the company in the last
few weeks the results are actually
pretty depressing if there a cide
research acts I've quoted three studies
here but you can find other studies as
well and here's what the studies did
they took the analyst forecast of
earnings for the next quarter they took
a Time series model forecast which is
just basically historical earnings
extrapolated and they look to see what
the standard error was in so the smaller
this number the more precise your
forecast so here's the good news all
these studies the analyst forecast
errors are smaller than using historical
data that's the good news the bad news
is you're spending I don't know how many
millions of dollars on cide equity
research to get a 3% Improvement in the
forecast ER and that's with one quarter
ahead if you go to one year ahead or
five year ahead there's not even that
small Improvement so which leaves the m
how come these analysts spend so much
time on these earnings numbers and these
companies to produce such terrible
forec so in fact about 5 years ago I was
I was giving a talk to sad equity
research analyst and I framed this
question you guys spend all your time
forecasting earnings how come your
forecast error is not that much smaller
than this historical data you know to a
person what the defense was it's not
us there are a lot of bad analysts out
there who are pulling these numbers
down the good analysts are much better
so I said
okay is there some way to to highlight
who the star analysts
are have you heard of all America
football teams the call It season or
they at the end of the season you they
pick across teams the best linebacker
best quarterback they have an all
America equity research analyst team
it's been around a long time
Institutional Investor used to be the
one that did it where they'd go know
sector by sector picking the
Superstar so these are the best of the
best right so I decided to take a look
at those All American analyst they must
be much better right their
forecast and there's some some evidence
maybe you can help me explain the
contradictions in here if you look at
these all America analysts and there
each year they get picked and you look
at their forecasting accuracy in the
year before they get picked they're
actually a little worse than the average
animals but the year
after they magically improved to become
a little better than the average ad this
must be the self-esteem you get after
you've being picked makes you better for
what do you think is happening here
first what does that tell you that
people with worst forecasting errors get
picked is All American what must go into
the Criterion for that pick um I don't
know about the criteria but maybe after
they get chosen compan yeah but who do
you think gets chosen you know because
this is actually a poll people vote for
it's a you know people vote for the all
americ analyst that's how they get
chosen so if you're looking at 72
analysts and can show you all their
names my guess is you won't recognize 67
of those names you know the five you'll
recognize is a if I got quoted all the
time now during the weekend I got um
email from somebody at Boston University
working on a
phq and he said I see you're on a list
of
influencers already my stomach drops he
said I'd like to interview you on how
you became an influencer I said right
after I watch Kim Kardashian
right but basically these are the in
they basically get their name out
they're like the social media Stars they
have 50 half a million people on your on
Twitter you're going to become an all
America analyst because people recognize
your name so first the criteria
obviously there nothing to do with being
good at equity research it's being good
at marketing yourself but what what can
explain the Improvement the year
after they're chosen as all America
companies try to match their you know
once you get picked as an all americ
analyst you make that part of your name
you're no longer Joe Brown you're Joe
All America analyst Brown this makes you
if you're a salside equity research
analyst and you become an all America
analyst you've just added an extra zero
to each Year's
income so when you call the company the
year before I'm Joe Brown from know
Oppenheimer not interested Joe hang up
the phone Joe All America Brown from
Oppenheimer all of a sudden the CEO
comes on and wants to convey you know
let's face it in the US it's very
difficult to you know it's it's illegal
actually for companies to give you
specific information they can give you
this fuzzy
stuff your information access
improved and here's why companies feed
information to all americ analysts all
americ analysts when they make a
recommendation the next day these are
the analysts that you see quote in the
Wall Street Journal you know so and so
from Morgan Stanley well recognized
analyst has put a strong Buy on this
company from just a
buy and the stock price tends to go up
and there's actually an asymmetri here
when all American analy put buy
recommendations the stock price
increases about 3 to
4% and if you track them a few weeks or
months later even that dissipates to
maybe 2% but when they put sell
recommendations the stock price drops 11
12% and it gets even worse in the months
after what it for that that buy
recommendations have so much less impact
than sell recommendations and sell
recommendations have far greater staying
power M
you perh because they don't usually put
first is the numbers right remember we
said nine times so and when you put a
sell recommendation you must really
really really really really want to cut
your Bridges with this company saying
that's as
decisive uh report from a so basically
there's more information to cell
recommendation
which has led me to
some internal
examination I think you I I I I don't
have a full count but I think there are
more probably 150 people whove gone
through this class who become sside
analysts I hear from many of them of and
on and I'm open about telling them that
sside equity research as we know it now
is
broken broken Bren why nobody listens to
you nobody's nobody's reading a report
for the buyer or the sell the heft that
you used to have is gone maybe you'll
get a little mention in the Wall Street
Journal and these are bright people so
it can't be that they're stupid so
there's something in the process that's
broken and I want to look at some of
those things but
Jessica would you quantify kind of the
qualitative aspects of a salside analyst
versus a tin ultimately there is no
qualitative payoff right if your bu
recommendations never work the fact that
your research report is really well
written or as deep thinking is this is
the most pragmatic of games buy I want
to make money sell I I'm going to lose
money and if it's not do doing that the
fact that you're an incredibly
intelligent person with an amazing
understanding of the
business like maybe like access to
management ability none of that is
paying off in better information that I
can use to that your buy so that is if
that is helping me in terms of your bu
recommendation actually leads me to make
money compound
so but the access clearly is not paying
off in good buy or sell recommendations
right so what does it tell you about the
access it's like a journal is saying
they have access to a politician right
they have access they get information
the information is in incredibly
biased you might play golf together have
a lot of drinks together but if that
information doesn't translate into
actual numbers in the future doesn't
help so here are the five things that I
think s Equity s equity research faces
as a problem that they need to
structurally fix first do you remember
how I said cide equity research is
organized you get hired as a salside
analyst by
Goldman what what the next thing they
tell you what sector you're going to be
following
right retail know media and then you're
given the 18 or 20 companies you don't
follow the entire sector you track you
know 20 big name
companies for how long for the rest of
your life already I'm getting a little
depressed right you're you're put into
the steel business or God help you the
airline business can you imagine having
to track the airline companies for the
rest of your life but you get paid well
he okay I can live with that but you see
that that this creates tunnel vision
because when you're doing these
companies what are you told ignore
what's happening elsewhere your job is
to focus on these 20 companies and act
like the rest of the world doesn't exist
that's the definition of tunnel
vision second a lot of leming
idas here's what I want you to watch for
in the news watch an analyst update so
during between earnings report to
earnings report analysts actually come
out with revisions to earnings per share
they say well I thought nedia was going
to make 17 cents but based on what I'm
seeing I think they can make 19 or 20
cents that's a revision upwards next
time you watch one of those revisions
track the new stories for the next few
days because you know what you're going
to see a bunch of other analysts also
revising there's a lot of leming itas
people kind of move together as a crowd
so everybody revises up everybody
revises down
the third is a variant of the Stockholm
syndrome you guys familiar with the
Stockholm
syndrome coined in the 1970s when people
were being taken hostaged by kidnappers
and the Stockholm syndrome
reflects the re the what they observe
which is in some cases the hostages
started identifying with their
kidnappers rather than the people Patty
H you know classic example you know cuz
she got kidnapped by the Symon's Army
you know and and then after a while she
became one of them and actually was one
of the biggest biggest people pushing
he's saying what's that got to do with
cide equity research remember I started
this process by saying if you're an
equity research analyst you're supposed
to look at a company ask questions about
the company and make judgments on buy or
sell after a while analysts seem to
forget that that's their job they think
their job is cheerleading the company
at Stockholm syndrome you've essentially
gone over to the wrong side there's also
a little faop phobia analysts write
hundreds and hundreds of pages lots of
nice pictures about the business and
forget to talk about value or Price
somewhere along the way and finally for
a long time and this is actually worse
outside the US now than in the US is if
you're anide equity research analyst at
Goldman Sachs and Goldman Sachs has
other business with the company that
you're tracking in you can already see
your tone in two directions right let's
say you want to put a cell
recommendation on
meta but Goldman Sachs has Investment
Banking business with
meta you're already going to be pushed
to modify it but in the late 1990s there
were sside equity research analyst Jack
grubman if you don't if you've never
heard of him you know wrri you know put
into go into Google search and type in
Jack rugman he's a telecom analyst right
I think it was for
Solomon you know was Notorious for
boasting to people about how much
Investment Banking business he brought
into the company with his
recommendations you cross the line right
so until we fix this process there is no
magical way for salside equity research
to improve so here are my basic
propositions you're valuing a company is
it useful to know what Salat analysts
are saying about your company absolutely
can't harm you there's not much
information that you're going to glean
from those because the biggest source of
private information are these little
driblets that they get from the company
which is incredibly
biased which can explain why all
American anals become better for
tests and
finally I think the value to knowing
what analysts think about a company and
I'll go back to Jessica's point is the
analyst that I think I listen to are
analysts who truly understand the
business it's not I don't care about
their buys and they're completely
useless but they do spend their entire
lives in the semiconductor business the
semiconductor analyst and they often
have knowledge about the business itself
a sense of perspective I could not have
so I'm not interested in their buys and
sells but I'm interested in talking to
them because so if you find a Sal side
equity research report ignore the buy or
the sell read the report to see if
there's something you can use in your
valuation about the business that can be
useful now if you're a private company
appraiser and there are hundreds and
hundreds of out there you know where
most private company valuations get
their earnings in cash flow
from the management of the company in
fact it's accepted practice why because
you can't push back right management
says these are the cash flows and it's a
terrible starting point for evaluation I
don't know how you even recover from
this because because the numbers are not
just bias they're often internally
inconsistent high growth no reinvestment
and you're stuck with those numbers so
what do private company appraisers do
the good ones they try to compensate for
the fact that the cash flows are
overstated by doing what what's the only
tool you've got left the discount rate
if you look at private company appraisal
they'll be adding all kinds of stuff so
you have risk free rate plus baited
times Equity risk premum you're not
stopping small cap premium company
specific to do what to kind of and but
you can see this is a game you can't win
you raise the discount rate managers
know you rais the discount rate what do
they do they push up the cash flows this
is a recipe for discounted cash flow
valuation where neither the CF nor the D
mean anything but that's the pathway
that private company appraisal has
chosen to
go so let's talk about the last way to
think about growth and the healthiest
way to think about growth I'm going to
set up a very simple business right now
it is a billion dollars invest in its
existing projects it's making a 12%
return so its earnings are going to be
$120
million next year the company adds a 100
million in new projects so think of that
as the Delta and the projects or
reinvestment in the in the way we think
about in cash flows and it continues to
make 12% you work out the math next
year's earnings are going to be 132
million you saying so what the change in
earnings was 12 million right where did
it come from
Delta in the investment and the return
you made in the investment we're laying
the foundations for what's called
sustainable growth sustainable growth
ties your growth rate to how much are
you reinvesting the delta in your
investment how well are you
reinvesting but to show you the cracks
that can come in sustainable growth this
worked because the return was staying at
12% let's say my return would go from 12
to
13% in other words I'm adding efficiency
I'm making my business your growth rate
is no longer going to be tied to just
your reinvestment how early reinvest
there going to be an efficiency factor
that captures the change in
earnings at many businesses with really
low returns this is your way of growing
it's not that you're reinvesting more
but that you're improving the return on
existing projects hey Boeing's growth if
there is growth in the future is not
going to come from reinvesting more in
fact they have exess cacity of 50% it's
going to come from improving margins
improving Returns on existing businesses
we're going to draw a contrast between
those two growth rates but first I want
to lay the sustainable growth foundation
for
you for for 80 years we've had
sustainable growth equations and again
people get very mechanical about the
oldest of those growth equations was for
dividends per share models where you
wanted a growth in dividends per share
so remember each one you're looking at
how much am I reinvesting how well am I
reinvesting so as I go through the three
variants I want to think about
consistency when you think about
dividends what's your definition of
reinvestment whatever is not paid out as
dividends right so you take whatever is
not paid out in dividends as a
percentage of net income that's called a
retention ratio so if your payout ratio
is 40% your retention ratio
60% and that money is getting reinvested
and what are you making on it because
it's Equity it's a return Equity
retention ratio times return Equity you
can think of his growth in earnings per
share that you use in a dividend
discount
model but we moved on from dividend
discount models to free cash flow models
right let's stay in the equity space you
go from dividends to free cash flow
Equity we no longer think of whatever is
not paid out as reinvested because you
might not pay dividence but that money
might not be reinvestment sit around as
a cash balance so we focus explicit on
what you're reinvested where net capex
change in working capital and if you're
thinking in terms of equity you're
saying well some of that comes from Deb
said equity reinvestment in the firm as
a person of net income instead of a
retention ratio is an equity
reinvestment rate so basically it's the
same game but you're focusing on
potential
dividends and you're focusing on what
actually gets invested in the company
your return and Equity is still net
income div by Book value of equity but
because you want to focus on things
you're investing in that are operating
you take out the effect of cash what
does that mean some of your net income
might be interest income from cash
you're going to take that out of the
process and your denominator which is
Book value of equity some of it might be
sitting as a cash balance you net that
out as well it's called a non-cash
return Equity because you're trying to
measure what the quality of your
projects are in your operations
are sustain this is a sustainable so
basically
but remember there will be a point in
your valuation where you have to hit
sustainable growth where is that
Gabrielle when year one you can get away
doing a dance of efficiency year two
more efficiency your three more
efficiency your five more efficiency and
then you get to your 10 and you tell me
that this is
forever so even if you never use I
hardly ever use sustainable growth
equations in most my company valuations
you but you get to your 10 you better
put in sustainable growth your balance
sheet will start blowing
up so we looked at two Equity variants
but let's say you're valuing the entire
firm their reinvestment is a percentage
of after tax Opera income does that
sound familiar because that's what we
start the free cash for the firm and
your measure of return is no longer
return in equity it's the return on
invested Capital the most misused
accounting Concept in valuation in
corporate finance now that Roy that
people throw around but already you can
see each one I'm looking at how much am
I reinvesting how well am I reinvesting
and your growth is the product of those
two so I want to kind of nail this down
because I said even if you don't use it
for year one year two you got to get it
in stable grow let's start with growth
in earnings per share retention ratio
measures what I put back give me the
constraints on that what's the highest
number of retention ratio can be 100%
what's the lowest 0% so it's con between
0 and 100 sounds obvious but nailed that
down so when I look at the growth in
earnings per share and my return Equity
is 20% with this equation what have I
just told you your growth rate cannot
exceed your return Equity because the
most you can have is a retention ratio
is 100% it's all about ret so here's an
example in 2008 before before the 2008
crisis I took Wells Faro doing
incredibly well like every other Big
Money Center back its return Equity was
17.56% its retention ratio was 45% which
means the payout ratio must have been
about
55% if I had assumed in 2008 that they
could maintain those two numbers their
expected growth in earnings per share
would be about
8% you see why I said if I this was done
in June of 20 June of 2008 3 months
later we got a reminder of
what that's 17.56% perc is really not
that high the retention ratio could
change and that's why you can see in in
when you assume what happened last year
as what's going to happen in the future
it could potentially get into trouble in
fact right after 2008 if you remember
the FED raised regulatory Capital ratios
for banks basically banking if I raise
regulatory Capital ratios what happens
to my return Equity they have to go down
have more Equity so even if they made
exact L the same amount of money as they
did before you're going to grow
slower because of the effect it's going
to have on your return Equity so that's
a simplest start but it drives driven by
having a high return Equity so how does
a company end up with a high return
Equity one is to take incredible
projects right in's return Equity Sky
High and even if we capitalize R&D it's
going to be 30 40
50% but can you take an average business
and Report really high returns in
equity when if you work in real estate
this is the name of the game Real Estate
is a boring low return business even
good buildings don't make 50% returns
they make 8% 9% returns so how do you
report a high return Equity by borrowing
to the health because your after tax
cost of debt is lower than the 9% so
effectively what you're doing is you're
taking the difference between the return
on Capital and your After Time tax cost
of debt and you're claiming it for
yourself as an equity
investor it's it's not unethical it's
not immoral it's perfectly okay so you
can have two ways of getting a high
return Equity right one is to take great
projects the others take average
projects and pump them up here's an
example Mev which used to be called
Brahma then that's how old this example
is a Brazilian beer manufacturer in 1998
had a return capital of 9 .9% pretty
impressive to begin with but they also
had a debt to equity ratio of 77% and
then after tax cost of borrowing money
was 5.6% that's a
14.3% spread you use 77 cents of debt
for every dollar of equity your return
Equity when all is said and done is
going to be
31% let's say have two companies they
have both at 31% returns and Equity one
got there with a lot of debt and the
other got there with no debt
in an equity
valuation would you value these two
companies the same or if you're going to
Value them differently what is the
vehicle through which you bring in the
Dead
Effect
Michael no that actually is going to
make it even better for the the company
with that right
yeah so you're going to reward the
company the more debt they have you're
going to be pumping up their Equity
value right
yeah no doesn't enter it's an equity
valuation remember when you have cash
flows Equity you discounted the cost of
equ now do you see why we went through
that torturous process of Levering and
unlevering bait it's not because I love
that
equation even though it shows up in
every Quest is it's precisely for
conditions like these because if you
pump up the dead and improve your return
Equity I'm going to say that's nice but
your cost of equity is also Rising with
it it's a difference that drives us if
your beta comes from a regression and
you have one cost of equity now you see
why private Equity investors and real
estate developers can essentially take
you to the you know take your money
effectively by promising these high
returns they're not lying about the
returns what they're not talking about
is the
risk one final example and we end for
the
day a few years ago about 10 years ago I
wanted to get a growth rate for
Coca-Cola and I wanted to focus not on
the dividend discount model but on what
they reinvested and how well they
reinvested so I looked at the equity
reinvestment rate net capex plus change
in working capital minus the debt
component that comes from it and divide
by net
income retention ratio Equity
reinvestment rate right with retention
ratios we set caps and Floors can't be
greater than 100% can't be less than 0%
with Equity reinvestment rates what's
the cap
or put differently can you reinvest more
than 100% of your net income yes by
doing what by issuing new shares by
raising new Equity can it be less than
0% yeah yeah you could basically be a
shrinking company of the% this is good
right because now if you gave me a
declining company to Value I going put a
negative reinvestment rate for a really
high growth company that so already
you're getting Freedom you did not have
with the retention
ratio and because I want to stay focused
in operations I'm going to look at the
net income net of cash and look at Book
value net of cash so here's the example
I'm going to end with there this is
Coca-Cola in 2010 had a non-cash return
in equity of 64% so when you take the
cash out of the book value it's tiny
amount why is it so high hey when you
sell a syrup that costs you 2% of your
product the only real expense you have
is marketing expenses what Equity
investment remember Coca-Cola also took
the only part of a beverage business
that's capital intensive and spun it
off the bottling 30 years ago they just
spun off so they just a syrup of course
I'm not surprised the ret the ret
reinvestment rate was Tiny again for the
same reasons you're not putting money
into the much money
so 63% return Equity 8% reinvestment
rate you take the product of those two
you get a 5.2 2% growth rate which is
not an unhealthy growth rate but it's a
growth rate that reflects being a mature
business with an incredibly great
franchise delivering 63% returns but if
you compare a 5% growth R Coca-Cola with
a 5% growth rate in
conad the 5% growth rate in Coca-Cola is
going to be more valuable to you as an
equity investor because they can pay out
almost entire earnings as dividends and
deliver the
5% conet might have to invest half the
net in come to deliver the same 5% again
we're looking for ways to reward and
punish companies that goes past the
growth rate and these sustainable growth
equations allow you at least think about
the implications so let's pause that
next session we're going to finish
growth and talk about the big enchilada
terminal value I'll send you a few posts
which you can read will help you kind of
in that discussion
I have
Grand
just
one
have retainer anyway